we're doing sunscreen reviews y it's
Michelle of lab muff and Beauty science
chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist and
sunscreen connoisseur today I'm talking
about a bunch of international
sunscreens I've tried recently all of
these are quite popular on social media
there's two from Haru Haru this video
sponsored the rest are sunscreens that I
picked up when I was in the US a little
while back for open source I've been
dying to try out some of these for years
and I know that a lot of us sunscreen
knows are not really that into US
sunscreens but honestly it didn't go
that badly not as bad as I expected
anyway I'm going to start with the har
har Wonder black rice moisture Airy fit
daily sunscreen this is a Korean
chemical sunscream with a different
formula from a lot of the ones that are
really popular at the moment I think
most people have heard about this like
family of Korean chemical sunscreens
that are sort of like variations on a
theme they use this blender filters they
each have slightly different skincare
ingredients and textures and they are
some of my favorite sunscreens of all
time but some people have told me that
they don't really like these formulas
they can have white cast on darker skin
probably because of that mbbt filter it
is a chemical or organic sunscreen but
it is in particles so it scatters more
visible light some people don't like the
texture and some people just find them
kind of boring so this Haru Haru
sunscreen is an alternative chemical
sunscreen formula which uses these
different filters and you will notice
there is no mbbt there so this one has
zero white cast on me and I've seen
reviews from people with darker skin
saying it has no white cast on them as
well it's also made by Cola which is the
big Korean sunscreen manufacturer that
makes a lot of the really popular Korean
sunscreens I'd say this is on the more
moisturizing and creamy end of Korean
chemical sunscreens but it is still
really lightweight with a cream gel
moisturizer consistency it applies
really smoothly and feels hydrating
without being greasy and it leaves a
slightly tacky moisturized feeling on
your skin I think a lot of people
underestimate the importance of the
inactives in a product when it comes to
the texture and the overall experience
of sunscreen so I'm going to talk a
little bit more about them and this is
actually like one of the few times I
think reading the ingredients list can
be kind of helpful to get the cream gel
consistency Which is popular in so many
Asian skincare products not just with
sunscreens but also with like
moisturizers formulas usually use a
polymeric emulsifier that means it will
hold the oily and watery parts of a
product together without needing as much
of those traditional emulsifiers which
can feel a bit thick and heavy closer to
the top of the ingredients list for this
is polyglycerol 3 diate this goes on a
little bit shiny but it sinks in pretty
quickly and it Glides on just so
smoothly there's no fragrance and it
doesn't pillow me and it sits really
nicely under my makeup in terms of other
skincare actors this has ceramides as
well as NY camide and adenosine and
that's what makes this a triple
functional Cosmetic in career in other
words as well as being an SPF it's also
brightening and anti- wrinkle har Harry
also has this other sunscreen which is
the black rice pure mineral relief daily
sunscreen this is another fragrance-free
sunscreen and it mostly uses zinc oxide
as well as an SPF booster this goes on
with a bit of white Cur which is what
you expect from a zinc oxide sunscreen
but it dries down to only a tiny amount
of white Cur it is as good as I've tried
with any untinted zinc oxide sunscreen
the Finish is not very greasy it's more
of like a Hydra finish and it is
slightly slidy so you can blend out any
white streaks pretty easily after it's
mostly dried down again this has a cream
gel consistency and it uses a poly
American msif this one is a little bit
worse just in terms of like reading it
it's polyglycerol 3 polymethyl siloxy
ethyl dimethicone I personally tend not
to prefer mineral sunscreens but this is
one of my favorite formulas so far again
it's from colmer and I just feel like
they really know how to make good
sunscreens that people enjoy using it's
also got nicomide hyaluronic acid and I
think that's what contributes to this
being not too drying and not too greasy
it is just hydrated which is pretty rare
with mineral sunscreens on my skin I
always love a good pump container with
my sun screens I find them really nice
and easy to dispense and you can easily
work out how many pumps you need to use
I personally have this problem and maybe
you do too I kind of accidentally just
start using less and less sunscreen over
time and I don't necessarily notice and
every once in a while I'll have to
recalibrate how much sunscreen I'm using
so pumps are really good for that
because then you can just say I will
always put on X number of pumps which
I've measured out once and never have to
measure again for my face these ones I
would need three pumps and it would be 3
to six pumps probably for most people
depending on the size of your face and
it also depends on how much of your
hands you use to apply because that will
also count as extra surface area and it
can be quite a lot both of these are
available from the official Amazon page
and the links are in the description I
picked up a whole bunch of popular us
sunscreens to try and this is really not
meant to be like a comparison video
because it would be pretty unfair to
compare us sunscreens with Korean
sunscreens they have different filters
and very different regulations so really
this is like a good opportunity for me
to get a bunch of sunscreen reviews out
there because I have a bunch piled up
that I just haven't released first we
have the super group unseen sunscreen
this is a really popular us sunscreen I
got a little variety pack from Sephora
which actually has really nice kits and
really nice like gift sets it's so much
nicer than Australia my Australian phone
number actually worked in their loyalty
card system which was pretty cool and I
got like a little birthday gift which
was nice I don't know I feel like we
don't have things like that in Australia
anyway this is p 40 it's PA with three
pluses and it is water resistant for 40
minutes which is quite unusual for a
face sunscreen so I quite like that this
is a chemical sunscreen and the filters
are I'm going to put them up here the
formula is really interesting it is a
waterfree silicone based formula and
when you squeeze it out it is completely
clear this sort of formula is usually
used in poor filling makeup primers and
honestly I don't really like these
formulas I find them really hard to
apply or rather they're kind of too easy
to apply so they glide on really nicely
but I can't get the full amount onto my
face so for my sunscreen reviews I
always weigh out the right amount of
sunscreen for my face each time just so
that everything is equal and fair with
these sorts of formulas it kind of feels
like I'm spreading icing on my face and
it feels like it's sitting on my skin in
a really thick layer sort of like I'm
slugging and it's not sinking in and I'm
just like moving it around endlessly it
does sink in a bit these formulas use a
lot of iso Doane as the solvent which is
volatile and so that of evaporates as
the sunscreen dries down as you're
applying it there is like this sort of
sventy smell but that goes away pretty
quickly one thing I do really appreciate
about these silicone formulas is how
matte they are when you put them on they
can get shiny after a few hours if
you're quite oily but they are pretty
impressive with the mattifying effect
but on my skin at least it kind of feels
like it just doesn't ever set properly
it feels like I have this film on my
skin even though it does look matte it
just sort of feels greasier than it
looks I I also feel like some of it
comes off on my fingers when I brush
against it even hours later but if you
have dry skin these do tend to do better
and they have a really nice smoothing
sort of makeup priming effect so yeah I
can see why this is so popular I think a
lot of people would love this sort of
formula but it's just not really for me
next we have the Trader Joe's daily
facial sunscreen this is very clearly
designed to be a dupe of the Unseen
sunscreen it has a really similar
ingredient list it really annoys me when
people say two products are juup when
they designed completely differently
with like different classes of
ingredients and the only thing they have
in common is literally they are both
sunscreens or they are both myel Waters
but this and the Unseen sunscreen are
actually functional dupes they have the
same SPF they have the same water
resistance they are both broad spectrum
they do have slightly different active
concentrations although they are the
same active so there is a little bit of
a difference but the biggest difference
is the price this is $9 for 50 Ms versus
I mean this is a tiny one but if this
was 50 Ms it would be $38 so like the
Unseen this has that clear formula is
silicone it is waterfree it starts off
with a slightly stronger solvent smell
that goes away again pretty quickly
after you start rubbing it in when you
squeeze this out it has a slightly less
smooth texture than the Unseen and it
feels a little bit thicker and heavier
on my skin but honestly the difference
is not that big so this is definitely
worth a try if you think this sort of
formula might work for your skin it is
really popular it works well for some
people I just prefer products that are a
bit lighter on the silicones and they're
more of that cream gel moisturizer
feeling rather than like a primer with
these two sunscreens I personally didn't
have any icing but I know some other
people have I really curious if anyone
has tried these two before and seen any
difference because yeah I did not see
one next we have the super GOP glow
screen this came in the pack with the
Unseen and the shade I got is sunrise
I've seen some people say that this is
the glowy version of unseen I don't know
exactly what they meant by that but this
is a really different formula this has a
cream gel formula but it feels very
different on the skin compared to those
other cream gel sunscreens I've talked
about today and that's because it has a
lot of makeup style pigment and effect
particles in it and that's all the bismo
oxy chloride Mica titanium dioxide and
iron oxides that are listed in the
ingredients list I actually prefer the
texture of this during application more
than with the Unseen it is a lot easier
to get that full amount onto my face but
after I dries down it does feel very
noticeable on my skin probably because
of all those Shimmer particles and the
stuff keeping the Shimmer spread out and
we need to talk about the Shimmer
because it is just too much if you use
like a sunscreen amount when you use
enough to get that full SPF 40
protection it looks properly metallic if
you apply it a really tiny bit so a
primer amount then it gives you a really
beautiful glow but yeah not with the
full amount and there's also this tint
which dried kind of orange and again I
don't think this is an issue if you use
a lot less but sunscreen amounts no
maybe it might work if you just happen
to be that exact shade but I think this
product is just better suited for people
who are looking for a primer with some
SPF protection and a glow rather than a
sunscreen so yeah I wouldn't consider
this a sunscreen really I would call
this a primer with SPF I am really
curious to know if anyone does like the
glow screen when they're applying the
right amount I feel like a lot of people
just aren't applying enough but yeah let
me know in the comments next we have the
blue lizard sensitive mineral sunscreen
I had to buy this when I was in the US
as like a souvenir because it's
Australian sunscreen but it is not
Australian apparently it did originate
in Australia but you cannot buy this in
Australia it's not on the Australian
register of sunscreens and that blue
lizard is not an Australian species Pro
tip if something is blue in Australia it
is probably tiny and surprisingly
dangerous and you should get the hell
away from it as an Australian The
Branding is just a bit weird but it is
really interesting to see what Americans
think of Australians this this is meant
to be one of the nicer mineral
sunscreens that you can get in stores in
the US it's got 80 minutes water
resistance which is nice that's the
highest you can get there the
ingredients which kind of worried me a
bit was titanium dioxide 8% and zinc
oxide 10% and no SPF boosters that I can
see so this should be a very safe option
for people who have a lot of chemical
sunscreen allergies but yeah the fear
for me is really just white cast so
during application this gave me a ton of
white cast but it did settle down
surprisingly well after a bit it does
end up greasy and there were like little
white flexes on my skin but overall I
was really impressed by how well this
went for an untinted mineral sunscreen
with no boosters it also has this cap
which is pretty cool it changes color in
UV which is kind of fun if you go into
the sun my partner did use this on a
beach date and he absolutely hated it it
just ruined his day because it doesn't
spread well and it was white and it kind
of just drags on your skin it takes a
lot of effort to spread but this is a
good thing for face sunscreens because
it means you don't have that problem
with the whole sliding icing thing on
your face when you're applying it the
final greasiness was quite a lot on my
skin and although I was impressed by the
lack of white cast or relative lack of
white cast I wouldn't wear this again by
choice it's just not good for my skin it
might be better if your skin is dry and
again it is one of the few options for
people out there where you don't have
any SPF boosters at all but I have
talked to a few people who have a lot of
chemical sunscreen allergies and they've
told me that Asian chemical sunscreens
actually work pretty well for Their Skin
So I think that's also worth considering
if you haven't gone down that road
before blue lizard do also have a sheer
lotion which is designed for the face
it's a bit more expensive but it has
less of those active ingredients they
were out of stock when I looked for it
but that might be a bit of a promising
option hopefully it is a bit more
wearable this was a little bit annoying
to remove because it is water resistant
and greasy but it wasn't too bad when I
used a cleansing oil first next we have
the Australian Gold Botanical 50 tinted
face this is the fair to light BB cream
again this is not an Australian
sunscreen it is not sold in Australia
the brand actually originated in Florida
I think on the front here these are
meant to be gum leaves which are
Australian but the leaves are like not
quite right they're like not quite the
right shape and actual gum leaves don't
have these like bold sideways branching
veins lab muffin Beauty science
australiana connoisseur this is spf50
broad spectrum it's also 80 minutes
water resistant and it's called zinc
oxide and titanium dioxide there are I
think three Shades available and this
was a pretty good color match for my
skin I would imagine that you would have
to have a pretty good shade match for a
product like this the color did dry down
slightly darker and a little bit more
orange than when I was applying it so
test it out carefully on your skin
before you commit it has eucalypt
extract and it does smell and feel a
little bit minty on the skin the main
thing that stood out to me with this was
how matte it dried it actually blew my
mind a bit it's like the opposite
experience to the blue lizard that tint
once it dried down just did not budge so
if you have it a bit streaky then that's
not great it is very much like a
foundation or like maybe even paint so
make sure you spread it out really well
it is a bit more drying than I like and
it feels a bit like I have a clay mask
on but it is also less drying than I
expected for that level of matte and non
shiny and feel I was expecting it to
really like give me fine lines and maybe
crack a little bit and maybe go a bit
powdery but no it was just like really
matte after a few hours I did see a
little bit of oil breakthrough around my
forehead and my nose but it was just
really impressive how matte it stayed I
don't think I've ever had that even with
makeup I can imagine that some people
are really after this sort of finish so
yeah I am actually really impressed with
this I haven't had a chance to try it
out on a really hot and sweaty day yet
so I'm curious to see how it holds up
and what it looks like after there is a
ton of oil and sweat and I think this
goes without saying but do not use this
if you have dry skin I really don't
think it'll work well for you maybe may
you can lay a moisturizer underneath and
make it workable but yeah it is matte
have I said that enough it is matte
getting this off my skin was
surprisingly not that bad I just used a
cleansing oil the skin 104 one and a gel
cleanser and that just completely got
rid of it I talked a little bit about us
filters today so if you want to find out
more about whether or not they're safe
they are safe I have a video about that
here you can also check out my latest
list of top sunscreens and those are
both Linked In the description